American sniper is currently one of the
most popular movies in the country it's
about the life of Chris Kyle the sniper
with the most confirmed kills in
American military history
it focuses on his life as failures and
successes and the trauma that he
experienced as a soldier but viewers of
the movie may be surprised at the way
that it talks about the Iraq war in
general from the very beginning of
Kyle's military career it's about a
response to terrorism he joins the
military after we see the bombings of
the American embassies in Kenya and
Tanzania and we see his and his wife tie
his stun reaction to 9/11 and shortly
after that we've got the Cowboys dog
child a blown Rock there's no
intervening time spent on george w bush
weapons of mass destruction or saddam
hussein the implication that the viewer
gets is that the invasion of iraq was a
logical response to 9/11 of course
that's not actually what happened we
know that after 9/11 the u.s. invaded
Afghanistan where Al Qaeda actually was
the decision to invade a rock came as a
result of pre-existing political project
that members of the Bush administration
had and was sold on the pretense of
weapons of mass destruction in Iraq the
main reason we went into Iraq
the time was we thought he had weapons
of mass destruction it turns out he
didn't but he had the capacity to make
weapons of mass but I also talked about
the human suffering in Iraq and I also
talked the need to advance a freedom
agenda in the movies narrative there's
no intervening time between the American
invasion and Kyl fighting al-qaeda in
Iran
he's trained by bin Laden he is loyal to
bin Laden his name is our colleague now
this [ __ ] is right now the crown
prince of al-qaeda in Iraq
that leaves viewers with the impression
that the Iraq war was against al-qaeda
at the outset and America invaded Iraq
because it had become a hotbed of
al-qaeda operations the reverse is true
al Qaeda in Iraq grew out of the u.s.
invasion it was weak and wasn't even al
Qaeda in Iraq when the invasion happened
its leader Abu Musab al-zarqawi
correctly assessed that the US invasion
would allow him to build up his group
Eastwood wanted to make a movie about
one guy in set out to make a movie about
the Iraq war the problem is though he
himself is anti-war he ended up letting
the film get wrapped up in Kyle's
perspective oh you want these
[ __ ] to come to San Diego or
New York we're protecting more than just
this dirt while it's easy to go sit at a
movie especially one that tries hard not
to shove politics in your face and
appreciate it simply a movie about
heroism this movie isn't just that it's
a movie that's going to leave viewers
with a false perception of what happened